Okay, welcome everybody to another Zoom call.
We got a bunch of questions that you guys shared,
and we'll get through those, those best I can,
and then we'll open it up for questions.
And remember, ask your question,
and most everybody did.
So everybody's getting on the membership site, I hope.
Ask your question on the box on the membership site
that makes it nice and slick, and if it's right to me,
I can see those.
Always when you have a question,
instead of waiting until Wednesday,
go to our regular website and do a search.
Now, I know we don't have a search feature
on the membership site yet.
We're working on that.
It's through a different company,
so we have to have them create a search feature.
So we are going to work on a search feature
on the membership site that doesn't exist at this point.
But go to our regular website, the contest.com,
use that little looking glass thing,
magnifying glass and search for it.
I'll say a couple of questions that were posted
are available in that, and I will point that out.
Hopefully everybody has got on the membership site.
If you have not gotten on the membership site,
what you need to do is search info at Cutters Clinic
or search membership on your made email.
So you're made email that you've used to initially contact us,
and then you may send in contacts to us in a communication with us.
That is the email that we register.
You can only have one email in the membership site.
That will be your user name.
And then you create your password.
So I'm going to that email for those who have multiple emails.
And search info at Cutters Clinic.com.
You'll find where you were invited to our membership site.
If you can't find that, just email me
at info at Cutters Clinic.com and say,
I can't find my invite.
And then I will click the box on the back office
and you will get another invite.
And then if it does end up getting pushed to like spam
or something, make sure you look at your spam.
So then you get in, you log in, you save your password,
and that's if you're forgetting it,
you could always have to just like any other site
to refresh your password.
But this has a bunch of information and answers
a lot of questions that only patients can see.
All our Zoom calls recordings are on there for the last six
years.
So make sure you go back and look at the user membership site.
OK, so here's a perfect question.
Share your thoughts on proton therapy.
Is it easier on your body than radiation?
I did a whole blog post on this.
And it should be on our regular website.
Proton therapy is a different type of radiation
that was touted.
When it came out a number of years ago,
it was a while ago, maybe 10, 12 years ago,
as a safer radiation than regular proton radiation.
Well, a regular radiation.
But in reality, I don't know that it's really proven
to be a whole lot safer.
I would still say if I had to get radiation,
I would find a clinic that had proton radiation therapy.
Versus regular radiation.
I just don't know that any studies have actually proven
that setting safer, but it is still radiation.
So radiation has its damaging effect.
So is it easier on your body than radiation?
Well, it still is radiation, so it
has just as much damaging effects.
What percentage of your cancer patients have the HLA-DQ
or that HLA-DRG?
I don't know.
In fact, we thought about actually hiring an intern
to literally scour our genes and our patients,
and be able to see.
Can everybody see my shared screen if you can?
See it, please say, yes, if you can see the Q&A at the top.
And the question that I'm going over right now,
please say that because somebody just did post
that they can't see the question.
No, can't.
OK, so we'll stop this share, and I'll do a new share.
Let's see right there.
OK, so now you can see it.
Yes.
Perfect.
Thank you.
So back to this.
This is where you look at your, for those questions.
This is the membership site that you should be looking for.
And this is the email if you are not in the membership site
already.
You're a full member of our clinic.
You need to be at your left.
There's a lot of valuable information.
You're not a full member of the clinic.
Should you mail some calls?
So everybody here is.
So make sure you get a membership site.
These are different genes that cause inflammation in the body.
Some have to do.
Some of these different variants have
to do with glee added sensitivity.
Some of them have to do with bold sensitivity
and other things as well.
But they all cause hyper-inflammation.
But we have never done a study.
We just don't have the manpower to do a study to have somebody
dig into everybody's genes and what type of cancers.
We always thought about doing that, but we have not.
What are the light colored seed pieces floating
in the toilet after voiding a coffee animal?
They look like pieces of chewed seeds.
It only happens with coffee.
And it is not regular voiding.
I don't know that I can answer that to anybody's satisfaction.
Certainly when you're using a coffee animal,
you are basically when you're voiding,
you have much more liquid stool.
Some of these things may be encased in a false bowel movement.
And you wouldn't see them in the stool.
That might be it.
I don't have any other possible solution or answer to that.
Certainly just could be partially digested seeds
or food or things like that too.
The other day I had what seemed to be
more like a bowel movement prepared to seem
like a more thorough bowel movement compared
to, since before, starting chemotherapy.
I noticed a small white, stringy, pitworm-looking thing
curved in this stool.
OK, I'm giggly because I love these things.
So I love it when people see parasites come out.
That's fantastic because you want to get these things out.
Now I don't know if it was a parasite or something else
that you ate.
I found a handful more and I'm unsure
if there are actual parasites or if they're fibers
or recently eating Jersey sweet cures today
after a coffee animal found more of these fiber-looking things.
I don't know unless you fish them out of the toilet
and you put them under a microscope
you would really be able to know.
Certainly if it's a tapeworm or a roundworm,
those are big enough to know what it is.
Pinworms are much smaller.
You can see those in the stool though,
but they're smaller and they're like
more grains of rice-type things.
So in order to know you'd have to do it in a study.
When you do a stool sample and they're looking for parasites,
they're really looking for the eggs.
Not so much the parasite itself.
MIT toxic parasites, well, certainly could be.
That would be an exciting thing.
Or are these things just common junk detoxing
from effective daily animals?
I don't know.
The truth is that most of us have a lot of cake to junk
on the sides of our intestinal walls.
So I remember reading what place,
and I don't know if you know this is true that they said
that John Wade, I don't know why they did it,
this study on John Wade's fecal matter
after he passed away.
But they said he had like so many pounds of fecal matter
cake to the inside of his gut.
I think this was actually in Robin's book
about that he wrote about, you know,
that was all anti-dairy and trying
to eat more of a plant-based diet.
And it was, they were talking about it
mainly due to animal meat products being
cake to the sides of your intestines.
Now, I don't know how much of that is true or not.
I have no idea.
But there is certainly a digested food
and junk in your gut that eats,
you know, that's your old detoxing that you're doing this stuff.
OK.
The ion railway foot bath appears to allow for toxins
from the body to be removed.
So yes, there's that.
That's some of that is taking place.
My bath water was filthy afterward.
I thought it was amazing that it works this way.
It's so much is taken out.
OK, let's stop right there.
So just because the water is filthy
doesn't mean that all came from you.
So there is some ionization that goes on with the ion railway.
So you are ionizing some of the minerals in the water.
If you just took the ion railway, then you threw it
in the bucket of water and you turned it on,
you would notice some discoloration of the water.
Now, typically it's not going to get awful
or black like if you had your feet in there.
So you are pulling stuff out of your body,
but don't equate to everything that's coming out of your body,
everything that's in the water is having come out of your body.
And certainly don't equate.
I've said this hundred times that the color, oh, it's green.
So it's coming from my mild doctor or oh, it's this color.
So it's coming from my liver.
There's no real proof that any of that is true
just because of the color.
So I understand that too.
Can too much be taken out of our body?
No, not with the ion railway.
But the different ionizing machines out there,
if you did them a couple of times a day,
yeah, you might pull out too many minerals,
but not with the ion railway.
You're mainly using it for the frequencies
that you're getting in the body.
The ion railway seems to allow for higher frequencies.
Yes, that's exactly right.
So you can use different frequencies with the ion railway.
I remember reading that some researchers,
maybe Royal Life,
who could have identified that frequencies
in the hundred to 300 kilohertz are responsible
for killing cancer.
So Rive did talk about higher frequencies several times,
but that's not all the frequencies that he used.
In order to get super high frequencies with a bulb,
you need to use a radio frequency bulb.
And even at that, it can be dangerous.
So the true right is what's called a high frequency machine,
not a radio frequency machine.
So there is a difference with that.
And if you want more detail of that,
you can look up some information
and take some courses through true right.
There can be benefits to using a radio frequency machine.
A GV4000 is a radio frequency machine.
There's also negatives to using a radio frequency machine.
Some of the negatives with the GV4000, though,
we have several at the clinic.
I have one at home when I don't really use it all anymore.
The negative is that it's bulky.
It's difficult to use the bulb that can use it's radio bulbs,
you know, like transmitter bulbs.
So it's a large machine.
It's not, you can't go places with it.
You couldn't take it on a trip with you
or something like that like you can with the true right.
You can't move it around the house
unless you put it in a cart and you're only in a one story house.
It's fragile.
It could break easy.
And it's not meant to be used overnight.
So you're using it typically just for shorter programs.
We have several patients that have a GV4000 also
that they might do during the day,
just to get some of the higher frequencies
because they don't like to use the bathroom, such that.
That's a possibility to do that too.
How important is it to have a ground beach sheet
under the fitted sheet, okay?
I have several videos on this as well,
but I'll just share this.
I know what to do, a person that asked this question.
So, depending on who you ask,
if you ask Mike, it's true,
I think he's gonna push ground beach sheet on everybody.
Again, a ground beach sheet, the frequencies
are gonna be attracted to that ground.
So if you have a ground beach sheet on your bed
and you're laying on your back
and you have the bulb on your tummy
and it stays on your tummy all night, I mean,
and you're sleeping on your back all night
and you don't move.
Well then the frequencies are gonna go through you
and be attracted to the sheet,
but you're gonna lose some of the frequencies
that would disperse up to your head
and disperse down to your lower extremities
because the frequencies are going to be attracted to the sheet.
Because that would be attracted to the ground.
So the sheet has got metal fibers in it
that that is attached to a wire that attaches to the ground
that then goes to literally the ground outside
if you're out that is grounded.
That's the idea of a ground, it's grounded you,
it's getting rid of positive charges on your body
that you pick up during the day.
Very beneficial to have a groundy sheet
if you have EMF issues and that is a major issue for you.
But if you're using the true life,
I always recommend that you,
if you're using the groundy sheet
that you only have it on the lower half of your body.
So the groundy sheet on the bed
is only on the lower half of the bed under the fitted sheet.
So if you're using a groundy sheet,
I recommend that you use it only on the lower half
of your bed underneath the fitted sheet to your feet.
And then you attach it to the ground
because you could be losing some of the frequencies
to the groundy sheet.
So that's my opinion.
You know, it's different than Mike's opinion,
but I'm not here just to sell groundy sheets.
You have that in the store if you want them,
it could be very beneficial especially for people
who have EMF sensitive.
But you have to just understand that frequencies
are coming out of that bulb.
You want them to transverse your body.
If you roll over the bulb falls on your sheet
and you have a full groundy sheet
and you're going to lose most of your frequencies to the ground
and you're not getting the benefit of them.
That's just my opinion.
Okay, talking about this person's son,
if she should avoid gold broth,
she should be avoid gelatin.
I've put in everything and powdered in gelatin caps,
especially greens and sunspectrum.
I can't get the greens in him at all.
Sometimes I can get the sunspectrum and a smoothie,
but usually not.
When you're dealing with a child,
sometimes it's very difficult to get them
to take any type of supplements and I get that.
I understand that you just do the best you can.
I don't know how much glutamine is in a gelatin cap.
We thought to do your research on that.
That's sure different gelatin caps contain
a different amount of glutamine.
So it is the glutamine that we're talking about
and glutamine, especially if you have this certain defect
in your genes will convert to glutamates very quickly.
So bowl broth has a lot of glutamine,
el glutamine, a lot of nutritional drinks
that to heal your gut contain a lot of el glutamine,
high concentrations of el glutamine.
But why?
Because el glutamine is a growth stimulator.
So it really helps increase replication of cells.
Well, boy, I shouldn't be drinking bowl broth
as a cancer patient.
No, no cancer patient should be doing a gap's diet.
A gap's diet is a diet where somebody
who's got really, really, really unhealthy gut
and they're using bowl broth
and they're drinking just very cooked soups.
They're making their own bowl broth
by boiling bowls at a simmer for several days
to try to get as much glutamine out of the bowl
and it's very healing to the gut.
Why? Because it causes rapid cell replication.
So should any cancer patient be doing a gap's diet?
No, I don't think any cancer patient should be doing bowl broth.
Now in that fashion, does that mean that cancer patient
can't have soup?
No, it's about balance.
You're going to get glutamine in other proteins as well.
But you're not making this concentrated glutamine soup
and you're certainly not taking high dose glutamine
in a supplement.
So remember, it's all about balance.
So you'll have to do your research whether how much glutamine
is in the gelatin caps.
Maybe the veggie caps are better.
I don't know why I haven't done that research.
On his own test, he has high markers for high external
as perjilous exposure or high internal yeast exposure.
Other than constipation, I don't think of him
as a candidate type person.
We have had mold testing at our home waiting for results
with everybody danger and giving him some grapefruit seed extract.
Probably not.
I would just start in low doses if you're concerned about that.
I don't think they'd be like the next part of this
says another practice that's just suggested killing yeast
can liberate heavy metals.
And that all has to do with killing yeast too quickly.
So you just want to go slow with anything
when you're dealing with any fungus or mold in the body
or Lyme disease, same thing you don't want to kill quickly.
You might want to just be running some of these programs
on your right for sheet instead of especially with him
when you're having trouble getting these supplements down.
If you have used your right then for these things.
Remember, underneath your program that I created for you,
there's literally 2,500 other programs for a lot of things.
Let that be your first goal to think
when you're looking at other diseases and such.
Constipation, I tried, they're ready to go.
That's a product by ortho molecular.
It didn't seem to help.
Started to give him magnesium citrate
because he had high oxalates at his oat test.
But it is taking three capsules to move the constipation.
I need to reduce his capsules.
His band constipated, though it was this copy twice.
So band really is not constipated.
What I would suggest though is if you want to reduce
your capsules and do the allol,
it's actually the product is ortho molecular product.
Super alo, 250.
And for somebody who you want to open up the capsule
and only give them a third of that at night before bed,
and just give them a third of the capsule, the super alo, 250.
If you are an adult and you have constipation,
start with the super alo, 250, start with one capsule
before bed.
This is the best thing for constipation.
You will get a little bit of cramping,
nothing like if you're taking a scena.
So super alo is a type of alo that is really, really good
for constipation issues.
So highly recommend that.
That will be much better than giving them the magnesium.
Remember when you're sending cheek swabs to us,
send it to our new address.
Continue to remind you about that, write that down
if you need.
When you're sending cheek swabs, make sure
you send it to our new address.
All right, some questions that you chatted in.
I have a growling blend essential oil.
Would it be beneficial to use this on my feet at night
when I'm cuddling with the right?
Would it work like a growling cheek?
No, it won't work like a growling cheek.
You won't lose frequencies to it at essential oil at all.
So yes, you could use that just by there's no negatives
about using that.
Now that it's getting warmer outside,
I'm spending my nights throwing my blankets on and off
repeatedly.
But that's all I'm sort of in here.
And I think that's a derivative I sleep a lot.
I'm used to cuddling with the bulb overnight,
but the heat it generates sometimes
could be contributed if I interrupted sleep.
Is it better than to push the bulb away or live
on a few feet or maybe get a better to better night sleep?
Yeah, you have to have a balance
while that could start getting a good night's sleep is not good.
I like a cool room to sleep in.
I just cannot sleep with what I feel like I'm hot.
So I know what you feel like.
So I open a window or go down the basement
if I have to to cool off.
So that's why I like to get rid of the sauna
because I would rather be cold and trying to get warm
than warm and trying to get cold.
It's just trying to be crazy.
I can't do that.
So I hear you.
Next question.
I gave blood for a Cyrex 10 test last Thursday.
They said you would get the results and not me.
That is correct.
We do get the results.
Not you.
How long does it take?
It's not busy.
They are usually it takes at least seven days total.
Sometimes seven to I've had a take two weeks.
But usually it's within two weeks that we get the results back.
Usually it's at least seven days, no seven to 14 days.
We'll get those results and we'll let you know.
Let's schedule the time to go over it if you need.
The Cyrex 10 test for those, though,
that is a blood test, a test for antibodies
to through over 300 different foods.
If you have a lot of inflammation in your body,
you cannot call the cell for some reason.
Doing that is a very beneficial test.
It's a great test for people that have autoimmune disorders
that they're trying to call them down as well.
Because if you have antibody study food that you're eating,
you may be causing a fire of inflammation in your body.
You don't have any symptoms of it.
So you could eat the food.
Well, I don't have any trouble with gluten.
I could eat it all day long.
But actually, you're causing this hyperinflammatory response.
It's affecting your gut.
That's affecting your brain.
That's affecting the rest of your cells.
And that can be a hindrance to healing.
So doing a Cyrex 10 test can be beneficial.
So that's what this person is talking about.
Any other questions?
Let's regard, if it bend is all,
the Josephine protocol recently recommended
taking it with a meal because fat somehow helped.
Well, I don't, Joe Tipens has added other things
to his protocol.
Burberry, I think you just added.
He added, take it with a meal.
Also, he now says, take it every day because it's not an issue.
So when we test people, so we don't use the Joe Tipens protocol
to understand.
So it is on our website with information
because it's Joe Tipens protocol.
And it's on our store.
We sell a Joe Tipens bundle.
Those are really to non-patients.
So when a person is a patient, we test them.
That's what you came here for us to get specific with you.
So we have a lot of people on bed bend is all.
This not taken the way he says it's taken the way
it tests out on a person.
So we have people take two packets a day, seven days a week.
We have people take two packets a day, three days a week.
We have people take one packet a day, five days a week.
It's all over the board.
It's dependent on what comes up with the test.
So if the person who asks this question,
I don't remember what your protocol is.
But if you're just choosing to do the Joe Tipens protocol,
which is everybody can choose to do what they want,
then you can play with those dosages and such.
Certainly taking, if you're following his protocol,
it's one packet of bed is all, which
is equivalent to use for a 10 pound dog.
So there is no side effects, no danger in taking that.
So no harm in tripling or quadrupling, your dosage really.
So you recommend three days on one pack, four days on.
If that's what I recommended for you,
that's what came up and you're testing.
That is, I think his standard protocol was three days
on, four days off.
That's what's on our website.
That's what's on our store.
I don't understand what's on our website.
What's on our store is for non-patients.
If that's what I recommended for you,
that's what I recommended.
If you want to take it every day, that's your choice.
But if you do just let your liaison dose so we can tweak it
in your protocol, what you are personally doing.
So remember, we are not our way or the highway type
clinic, we, our patients, the freedom
to be preyed about what they should be doing.
And certainly if they feel like they
should be doing something else, we want you to do that.
But I do ask that you just communicate that with us,
so we can least put it in our notes as we know what you're doing
so we can have it in our master list of your books.
Next question, said starting the hyperthermia,
this is person started using a hyperthermia unit at home.
On my liver, I've noticed amber or concentrated
looking urine intermittently.
I looked at a functional websites
and found that correlation with liver function in this symptom.
My liver values are elevated, but my bun is normal.
That's your blood, urea, nitrogen.
Lab, grant, urine, screen, all normal.
I am definitely hydrated, okay?
That would be question number one.
Three liters of water and a cup of tea or so a day.
I create and was a little too low over hydrated
and was told to be.
Is it typical to see this amber urine with hyperthermia
or other liver supporting therapies?
I have not done the hyperthermia for a few days due
to my chemo and port schedule and urine cleared up.
Just see a correlation with hyperthermia.
I have not heard that before my question is
if you're just using it for 40 minutes a day over your liver
or if you're using it multiple times over your liver,
that would be question.
I have not had anybody say this comment before
so that's interesting.
I'll have to do some investigation of it.
Very questions.
I've had a long history of candida and a herxine
when treated it.
For the first three weeks of using the right,
I felt good the last three weeks I felt
I have been getting some ticks more anxiety
paid in the chest, muscles, sternum and other things
possibly herxine the candida.
So are you using the program that I created for you
or are you ready to candida program?
Could this be a herxia reaction for candida
or just normal for the right program?
So if you're ready, the program that I created for you
you won't be herxine from candida.
So I would have to look,
when was your program updated?
Contact your liaison and let me know.
I get a right to read and see when I updated your program
and if not, we might want to get a cheek swab update
that if I have an update.
So I didn't get my genetic test back.
I think it's still that the eight week period for that.
Okay.
So you started with us about eight weeks ago?
No, well, I've only been using the right for six weeks
and I think that it took me another week.
I'm not exactly sure, but I know my genetic test wouldn't be back yet.
Okay. So don't need your genetic test.
I'm just wondering what right program you're using.
Oh, I'm not using any candida programs at all,
but I've been using all the programs you wrote for me twice now.
And so I had 21 programs and I've gone through that two times.
Okay. So let's have you said it at other cheek swab.
And I want to look at your program and possibly do some updating.
You have a cheek swab in your binder.
Yeah.
Send that in and I made a note to look at programs and see how we can tweak that.
I haven't used any candida programs, but I've been using all kind of other programs
like for attention deficit or for this pain I have in my chest,
I've been using the pain like bio basic and those ones should do that either.
Okay.
Are you you're not using any other kill programs like a bacteria or a lime or a mold?
No, none of those.
Okay, because this is known for everybody.
If you're if you're ready, like I just said a couple minutes ago,
run those other programs that are in your on your right.
But if you're running kill programs or kill program would be for a bacteria or a lime disease or a mold.
You can't hurt because this thing works and it can kill and it can't kill too fast.
So what a herxime reaction is is that you kill a bacteria too quickly or a fungus or a mold too quickly.
You end up with byproduct of the organisms spilled into the blood, you know, just waste.
Spilled into the blood and that's what a hook cyber reaction is.
So you could get really tired, you could feel yucky, you could feel sick,
could just be a gamut of different symptoms.
And it's because you're killing too quickly.
We see this a lot with lime patients, very kind of like my patients,
you have to go really slow with kill programs.
So let me look at your program.
Let's get an update.
Send in the sheets. We'll take a look at that.
Put in the membership link.
Yeah, so if you're having.
If you have not been on the membership site.
Go to look at search your e made email at info and cuttersplotic.com or just email me.
At info at cuttersplotic.com will tell you please I'm not able to get on the membership site and I will send you with either link.
And then make sure you search for that other link.
In your.
In your judgment.
My mom has liver affected due to fluid accumulation in her stomach area.
How detox must be done.
Just got all your stuff for your mom.
So just start there.
You don't want to try to detox too quickly or anything like that to start using the right.
Follow what is in your binder and take the time to stop and open it up and read it.
And use the right on her 24 seven if she's not fully ambulatory up and moving around and live in her life.
So use the right as much as possible on her anytime she sit down.
You want to set up your home that she could be right feed.
And then that how you would help with detox pathways and deliver you have to go back and download on the website again.
Download you just that's the main website think it's on the membership site to go to the main website look for books download the detoxification book to help you understand that but you.
The person has got to be.
I'm happy to ball move into the least one a day make sure they're moving their ball.
And then you work on other things up stream from that.
And helping with the liver using a hot pack over the liver could be beneficial.
Past oil pack over the liver could be beneficial.
Coffee and others are one of the best things to help with all of the pathways.
So other questions.
Okay, well, we will end that now this I will have time tonight to get this uploaded to YouTube and you'll see it under the membership site.
You're on this.
And again, if you really want everybody to use that membership site.
So if you're having trouble to get on and there anything you need to do.
Invite you.
All right, thank you guys.
I'll be praying for all of you and we will talk again next week.
Thank you.